- I love that your outfits
are throwback as well, ma'am.
That was nice.
- It is a little core set.
- Probably planned it's nice.
So wait, explain for those
that haven't seen the show,
like what's it about?
- Okay. So imagine I'm
in a castle with 16 guys
and they're all fighting for my love.
Which is so crazy.
And basically my parents
are there as well,
and my sister, and my best friend.
- It just became a different show
when you go for parents,
- No, I know.
- but yes.
- I'm like,
"I should have given a little bit more."
Okay so it basically, it's
a Regency style dating show.
So think like "Bachelorette
meets Bridgerton".
- Oh, yeah.
So what are the similarities?
It does look like Bridgerton.
So what are the, and it
looks familiar, The Castle.
- Yes.
So The Castle is actually the same one
that the Duke of Hastings lived in, right?
And that's-
- Nice.
- Yeah right, it's so cool.
(audience applauding)
And that bed,
that they had their relations on
was the one that I got to sleep in.
- Their relations?
(laughing)
- You are keeping it
high class, relations.
- They're really (laughing)
I love that.
I'm gonna forever call it relations now.
So wait, so you're a software developer.
So what made you wanna
try this experiment?
Were you just like, I'm over dating?
- No, I mean, yeah.
As a software developer.
I was on dating apps, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I had no luck.
I mean, I dated guys from dating apps.
One of them I'll never forget.
I show up and I did three laps
around the bar because I
couldn't find him, catfished.
- Because he didn't look like his.
- Didn't look anything like a photo.
- See.
- Now I'm like, what happened?
This guy was like-
- What are they thinking?
- 70 pounds heavier, like
different hair color.
I'm like,
"At least wear a name tag
or some... (laughing)
- I mean, here's making to
like people are going
to see you eventually.
- Yeah.
- Like how?
- No, exactly
or I went on another dating app date
and this guy I show up and
it's just a casual night out
to get drinks.
And he's literally wearing a full on suit.
He's sweating, profusely.
Can't look me in the eye.
- Oh.
- I'm like you poor thing.
I don't think he's ever
been on a date before.
(laughing)
- Well, you're incredibly
good looking too.
So that probably made him nervous.
He was sweating.
Yes. He was probably like,
"What am I doing here?"
- He's like, " I don't know".
- Did he at least look like his picture?
- He did.
- See.
- He did look like his
pictures and that was good.
- That's points.
- It's sweet, but it's like,
it's so hard to develop
a meaningful connection
when you're on a dating app.
And you're only looking at,
where they live, their height,
where they're from.
Like that doesn't tell
you enough about a person.
- Especially when they
lie about their height
and all other things
- Yeah exactly. (both laughing)
Like it's not even them.
- They're like lies and deception.
So wait, who's on your court.
Is that your family?
- My family, yeah.
So my mom, dad, my sister.
- [Kelly] So do you like?
- [Woman] It's interesting I have to say.
- [Kelly] That was (indistinct)
- I know, I know.
I'm gonna be real.
It was really fun having them there,
but I've never had my
family see, they're so cute.
I've never had my family involved
in my love life like that before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I remember the first
time kissing a guy on the show,
I was literally like,
"Oh, please let me fall
through the ground."
Because my parents are
probably like, "Oh gosh."
- Oh gosh and so what.
Well everyone kisses.
We're all old enough.
But, but it is awkward I guess.
Okay. So what did you learn
about men while doing this show?
Cause everybody was,
you're like fencing and
doing different things so-
- Yeah. So we're playing
all different kinds
of games together, cricket, we're fencing,
we're going on, boat rides,
guys are helping me on and off of a horse.
It's so different from modern day dating
and we don't have technology.
And I think what was so special was that
I really felt like I was able
to develop a deeper connection
because we weren't on our
phones the whole time.
And we were dancing at
balls which was so fun and-
- (indistinct) dress up.
That's fun.
- Yeah and play dress up
and I just feel like I
got to see these guys
like really let their guard
down and be vulnerable.
And I always said from the beginning like,
"My guy's here, because he's willing
to put on tights in a covert
and dance on a ballroom floor."
Like that's my guy.
- Yeah.
- Just, you know.
- Lean in.
(audience applauding)
- Yes. I always say somebody
that's down to beat down
and like these guys are down to beat down.
- Cause you don't wanna be with the guy
when you're going to a theme
party and they're like,
"I don't wanna put the costume on."
- Yeah. I'm like...
- I don't (indistinct) get outta here.
- That's so high school.
Like don't act like a cool kid.
- That just means you're insecure.
- Agree.
- Yeah. I'm over that.
Okay. So what was the worst part
of having to act like it was 1820?
- Yeah. The bathroom situation.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't know how women did it back then
but the long dresses and the core set.
And then you go and use a bathroom
and you walk in and it's a wooden toilet
with like a one wooden plank on top.
I'm like, "What in the bathroom?
Who's gonna use that?"
So I'd have somebody hold my dress out
like it was my wedding day
almost every single time.
- Oh my gosh.
- You got real close to people.
- I did. (laughing)
- You were like so I gotta
go to the bathroom my bad but
- Yeah. Sorry about it.
- Come with me.
- And you help me with my dress.
- It is so true.
It is that wedding day moment
when you're like it's awkward
and you're in a (indistinct)
Yep.
- Yeah.
- All right. Well there's
no segue from that.
We need to do another commercial break.
"The Courtship" airs
Wednesday nights on USA
and streams next day
on Peacock, everybody.